[Music]
last week social media absolutely lost
its mind when Serena Williams posted
this photo announcing she was 20 weeks
pregnant that's right but then she took
the photo down so we were all wondering
is it true but Fenn Serena confirmed the
news so why all of this confusion Serena
is gonna clear it all up getting ready
to go on stage for my first hip hop and
that TED talk came with a confession
Serena didn't mean to reveal her
pregnancy Serena says she's been taking
weekly picks up her bump and she
accidentally made this snapchat photo
public and immediately the secret was
out telling the crowd my phone doesn't
ring that much and 30 minutes later I'd
miss four calls so I picked it up and
realized oh no the 35 year old tennis
champ is 21 weeks along with her first
child the dad is her fiancee Alexis
Ohanian co-founder of the website reddit
I would never put you with the nerdy
geek and you me neither I'm gonna be
honest with you I I didn't either but
it's been the best thing for me Serena
admitted to CBS this morning's Gayle
King she never considered herself the
marrying type and that when Alexis
popped the question she was actually
upset saying quote I was angry because
it was right in the middle of my
training season and I thought I have to
win the Australian Open still Serena
said yes and went on to win the
tournament squaring off against her
sister Venus in the final all while
eight weeks pregnant and there's no
question the 23 time Grand Slam champ we
back on the court after the baby is born
I definitely plan on coming back I'm not
done yet my baby's gonna be in this
dance and hopefully cheering from me and
that crying too much did you get a
timeout to go to her baby I don't think
so
[Music]
you